[Music]
lady gaga
opens up about the new film Gaga thy
foot - are you nervous watching no I'm
excited
eg spoke with the 31 year old singer
during the world premiere at the Toronto
International Film Festival on Friday
about the new Netflix documentary she's
featured in that was directed by friend
and filmmaker Chris McCarville I
actually haven't seen the film yet I'm
gonna see it for the first time right
now I wanted to share a bit of myself
that I hadn't shared it yet with the
fans but I didn't want to do it on my
own I don't think that I can be
objective about myself I don't think
that I would have an ability to craft a
piece of me my biggest fear was that it
would be commercial or that it would
lack in authenticity and would feel as
though I was pandering to people to love
me so I gave Chris full access once I
decided I
and I'm excited to see what they created
you know they're wonderful amazing men
in my life and Chris is no exception I
loved hearing things that we will see in
this box that you'll see for the first
time of the pointer one of the things
that stood out for me is that you would
run off stage on occasion and ask your
boyfriend like how your performance
didn't why is his important important to
well you know it's not just about it
being my boyfriend I I asked that of
many people in my life and my family all
the time at the end of the day I'm my
father's daughter I'm my mother's
daughter and my sister's sister you know
I feel so honored to be wearing my
sister's jacket tonight that she
designed with Lunada studios I'm just
happy to be here with my family and
wearing our creation
[Music]
you